with work work wives and work husbands
there's more of like an emotional thing
going on like you're at work you're not
going to be and if you are then good
luck keeping your job but uh it's
usually like oh so I had a problem with
my wife back home and then the man comes
in and like confides in you I've had men
do that when I used to work in sales and
they'd complain about their girlfriends
it's like they're looking for that
almost emotional support to feel about
it and vice versa women do the same
thing
um they were pillow talking not pillow
not sexting or anything like um no
pillow talking meaning
they didn't separate their personal
relationship from what it was that they
was dealing with when they were dealing
with you